i'm truly pulling for leah right now but
it could have been so much better shaky
on a scale 1-10 it was a 3.
all right brookie-boo here we go head
over let me see it shake it down feather
ah
shake it well i heard about the girl
you've been dancing with all over the
neighborhood
so why don't you ask me baby
or didn't you think i could
that was a really good brooklyn really
good
here's the situation i assigned some
roles that i thought i was sure of
kaya you know you will be singing thank
you
thank you so much kinley you will be
singing for sure
thank you so much
brooklyn you will be singing
[Music]
as much as i wanted leah to hang on to
her spot she just didn't come through
for me i mean brooklyn came in and swept
it brooklyn wanted it
and
to change it up we've decided to add a
fourth spot this week
[Music]
to change it up we've decided to add a
fourth spot this week
the fourth spot
is going to tiny t
all right let's do the dance
mama
i'm sorry i'm sorry you're tough okay
if it's your last week just do the best
you can that's all you can do go dance
good and do the best you can do right
i love you it doesn't matter if anybody
else does i love you she doesn't want
her in the group that's fine send us
home we've got other stuff to do
don't i okay
so you three are gonna do five six seven
this is come on let me see you shake
your tail feather freeze here and then
you're look where you're at center for
well i heard about the girl you've been
dancing with
come forward and live that life cool
you've been dancing with
all over the
neighborhood cool makes sense yes she's
actually gonna get in front of a dance
for once
oh i don't think she set the formation
yet because you know how she changes it
all the time i don't think he's not
singing no i'm saying as far as the
singing she changes the formations right
so i want you to start up on this okay
careful cause these spin beautiful
brooklyn and kyah right here and right
here leah tiny t
and then let's do dallas and tatum come
sit in the booth yep
i'm like brooke like last week during
competition
when
nobody went home she was like mom
everybody's happy yeah and that's like
the feeling
i have too
yeah
i mean you can't expect me to sit here
and be happy i'm not pointing you out
and that is like i'm not pointing you
out
i don't take it as brooklyn stole the
spot from anyone like i was trying to
tell brooklyn i was like think of it
this way from the time you step in that
room until they say your name is in this
group treat every day like an audition
she earned it she worked her butt off
we'll clean it up when we get there what
i want to do now is i just want to go to
the beginning and work our way forward
[Applause]
[Music]
tayden you okay stay out
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you guys
it's chilly i didn't want to take like a
lot of time in there and talk because i
know jojo was like wanting to do the
dance yeah we were a little stressed
about the time too
yes
but you know like
something's happened obviously
yeah
tayden forgot the words i don't know why
what she's trying to do is take your
feedback of just being like her
personality and more bold and she knows
what i told her is keep your eye on the
prize which is making the group i do
think that leah is
sad it wasn't easy you know honestly i
thought leah would be fine
and she just wasn't her best audition
brooke had a fabulous audition thank you
now you're welcome all right i'm gonna
go just take a sec okay
oh
i'm tired of talking about it i'm tired
of crying about it it is what it is
i hear what angie's saying under her
breath i'm not feeding into it it's her
job to pull herself together and be
professional here in hollywood you get
told no a lot it's your ability to
control yourself and pull yourself
together
that defines who you are
i'm nobody obviously my kid is nobody we
just have to do what we're told i'm not
i'm done i don't give a crap i don't
want to talk about crap i don't want to
talk about anymore
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you